experimental economics destroyed
whatever was left in me in the notion
that that somehow you could do better
than to find institutions that organized
this decentralized information and
create hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason
TV and today we're extremely happy to be
talking with Vernon Smith the 2002 Nobel
laureate and economic science
Vernon thanks for talking with us Nick
it's great to be here
you won your Nobel in experimental
economics a pioneering field give us the
measure where is experimental economics
today compared to where it was when you
were awarded the know well of course the
award did I think attract a lot of
attention the experimental economics
well I wouldn't you know it's
experimental economics is still not
mainstream economics and it's just I
think much more important or more
influential in some ways it's sort of
similar to economic history we're
sitting in your office in Chapman
University beautiful campus in Orange
County California
tell us about your setup here and what
kind of experiments are you running and
what are you hoping to find through them
one of the classic experiments I'm
involved in now it was a return to the
asset trading experiments that we did in
the 80s and in particular we're asking
some questions that have come out of the
economic crisis because we started doing
asset trading experiments in the 80s and
discovered bubbles quite unintentionally
in your experiment you were able to
create bubbles or they they just popped
up they popped up and in fact the
baseline that we were running we thought
would be so transparent that we wouldn't
observe bubbles but we thought we would
with that baseline see if we could
create bubbles but we never had to how
does a bubble take place well it goes in
the fundamental value is falling like
this okay
saying one of the designs from $3.60 a
shared at twenty four cents a share the
typical pattern for
experience subjects is that the trading
begins below the fundamental value the
trading prices rise and break through
this falling declining fundamental value
and they'll go up and reach peak and
collapse us at the end they don't
recognize that the value is declining or
they don't care let me just say right
now that we don't understand why it is
that people get caught up and self
reinforcing expectations of rising
prices what they do is with experience
they come to believe this information we
give them is important because they get
there by experience you see the first
time you're in this experiment you may
have bought early and you may sell
before the break no one can tell you
that you tell you you did anything
irrational rude bring those same people
back and another two or three days put
them in the same environment and we get
a war volume bubble sometimes I'm
typically it booms earlier and crashes
earlier well to some extent you see they
vary expecting a bubble bring them back
a third time and now they tend to trade
fairly close it's a fundamental value
how would does this type of experiment
map on to I don't know so maybe the last
five years in America if you think about
the housing bubble buyers sellers
borrowers lenders real estate agents
government regulators everybody believed
that prices would rise and continue to
rise and that is is kind of the essence
on one of these of a bubble suppose a
regulator in 2003 therefore said hey
this thing is not sustainable we've got
to do something to stop it I think he'd
have been fired right if the bubble had
been stopped say in two thousand three
or four it'd probably been a lot a lot
less damaging but who's gonna know that
right now in your experiments who are
the who are the
people who are running the different
rounds of bidding and things like that
you bring in students should bring in
professionals we started out with
undergraduates in frustration in 1989 I
went to Chicago and we recruited a bunch
of over-the-counter traders and brought
them in we had a lab set up there and we
got a bubble room so we soon established
that this wasn't anything but peculiar
about to them to the undergraduate
subjects we were using why has it taken
so long for economics to really kind of
try and become more seriously empirical
in its operations it really seems like
it's taken forever for economists to
actually want to observe actual human
beings trading either in an experimental
setting or in the real world economics
enjoyed a major breakthrough in the
1870s the marginal revolution and give
us the two word of definition of the
marginal revolution well if you go back
to Adam Smith he was puzzled as to why
diamonds command a higher price than
water would but whereas obviously water
is more useful and the key idea didn't
have is the notion of marginal utility
our marginal value and unfortunately I
think we lost a lot of the other
insights of Adam Smith you see because
we would solve this intellectual problem
of understanding kind of better the
determination of prices an equilibrium
economics really became in the driver's
seat which holds the idea is an economy
consists of preferences and technologies
for producing goods this gives you a
conjunction of supply and demand where
demand depends not upon the price of
this particular good but of the price of
the alternatives because the concept of
opportunity cost comes in on both the
demand side and the supply side and so
it's a complex problem mathematically
and
but this problem got solved and it
helped then to understand the operation
of a static equilibrium world of course
the great insight of hike and his
criticism of equilibrium theory was that
it began with a bunch of Givens that are
not in fact given to any one mind in the
economy and and that the essential thing
about a real economy is that all this
information is dispersed so that the
name of the game really is how it is do
people discover these equilibria and
that's of course where I think the
experimental work has importantly
dramatized the essence of Hayek's
critique given existing institutions of
trading people are very good in the
laboratory at finding these equilibria
that they don't have any understanding
of and they get there by repetition
you're a pretty hardcore libertarian you
say you're a libertarian with a lot of
reservations and whatnot in the
experiments that you run and and the
research that you've done over the years
kind of really argues that institutions
create the behavior that is either good
or bad well it's as a libertarian and I
like to emphasize the property rights
aspect you know but people say they own
what we need is more regulation well
listen all markets have are regulated in
terms of property rights that you know
do's and don'ts and the the important
thing is that those property rights
provide people with the right incentives
mm-hmm was so devastating in a mortgage
market is this separation of mortgage
origination from the lender without
properly incentivizing the mortgage
originator what's your incentive to do
due diligence if you get your fee
upfront and then it goes out the back
door and sends down the lines you know
comes a lender's to buy it borrow them
you say we got away from you no kind of
understanding that yeah everybody needs
to have skin in the game during the long
haul in order to that you know that
you're not just spending other people's
money and hoping for a quick cash out or
redoubling of your investment what was
driving that loss of knowledge I mean
was it was it federal policy was it kind
of collective amnesia because we are all
now the way I would describe it is that
we created new mortgage and financial
institutions just too fast we did it it
was no one hadn't had an insanity to
think it through not only was there bad
incentives up front with mortgage
origination but those mortgages then
would be packaged and mortgage-backed
securities issued and then they were
rated and insured quote insured but they
weren't collateralized they were exempt
you see and and an exempt meant they're
exempt from the property right rules
that would have applied if they've been
if derivatives had been classified as
securities this has been a very long
recession and whether or not it's
technically ended or not we're facing
slow economic growth we're facing high
unemployment for you know as far as the
eye can see really what what are the
forces that are extenuating or extending
this well I think the main problem is
the negative equity problem in
households or near-naked
negative equity and you have something
like 22 percent of homeowners now who
owe more on their house and then the
current market value you don't feel like
spending money you're paying down debt
what do you do I mean you just set it
out until enough of the debt is paid
well I think that's probably the way
we're going to do it mm-hm
it was a mistake to subsidize new
homebuyers existing homeowners many of
them giving a break in their payments
but they've done it by giving them a
lower interest rate and stretching the
loans they haven't changed the principle
but that's a disturbing intervention as
an of course
disturbing forgiving debt is not a good
idea but you have to realize we don't
face any good option if it hadn't been
done the the banking system would likely
have collapsed we've had the same
problem we had and they in the thirties
is that what we've been going through
here if it's if it's the second worst
kind of fiscal crisis except for the
Great Depression in the past hundred
years or in the past 80 years whatever I
mean how does it stack up because I
remember the thirties like it was
yesterday and see in 1932 I was five
years old my father worked for the
Bridgeport Machine Company in Wichita
Kansas he was he was a machinist we had
a farm so in 1935 we moved to that farm
be-caw and and it's interesting because
in times of stress there's often this
reverse migration from cities to farms
because in the farms you can eat right
grew our own vegetables chickens hogs
all of that and they were very very
difficult years in terms of wheat
harvest then that sort of thing you grew
up in Kansas and the in the 30s and then
in terms of high school yes I finished
high school in January 1944 I was
working at Boeing at the time and I
continued until the following August of
1944 and then I went to fringe
University Quaker College not many
blocks from where I lived and the reason
why I went there was to get make up from
my high school education I had been I
was not a good student in high school
and I didn't have
the math physics chemistry that I needed
if I was going to go into science I made
up for all of that and friends
university did others your parents go to
college No so how did you gravitate
Tevan thinking of that as a possibility
my parents always expected of me even
though they only had an eighth grade
education there were people who read my
mother was a was a socialist Jen was a
political activist
when you say socialist I mean she
believed that the ownership of the means
about oh yes
production should be collectively owned
by the state etc yes but that was that
was really common run when people in the
1930s especially in that part of the
country oh yes you've got a master's in
economics from Kansas and then you went
to Harvard for your PhD
what were they teaching in economics
classes general equilibrium theory the
course I took from Aussie liliani F
which was the first year Theory class
Harvard was a very good one we read
Irving Fisher and I'm still a great
admirer what do you like about him
Fisher was a very clear writer I
remember a student once asked Oh Leon EF
in class why there was no a no School of
Economics build around Fisher no Liana
have said well it's because he wrote so
clearly everybody could understand what
it was they were people free-market
enthusiasts at that point or were they
all talking about a kind of command
economy or heavily regulating I think
the only clear clear-cut free-market
enthusiast at Harvard would have been
Godfried hablar mm-hmm and he'd come out
of the Austrian school it was a
tremendous exodus of course out of
Germany and Austria not only physicists
but he caught rose and Fritz makalu
Jacob Marshak
Shoom Pater of course and when I got to
Harvard
Shoom Pater
and died only of two years earlier and
his legacy was very strong was there a
sense that FDR's economic policies and
his brains trust that they had actually
succeeded or you know and that you were
just kind of I mean that economists
could follow through on that project yes
it was in a way it kind of saved
capitalism just like George Bush tit
more recently yes he saved it in fact my
my grandfather my mother's father who
was a had been a supporter of Eugene
Victor Debs
in 1932 became a Roosevelt fan and I
think that tells you a lot about what
happened in the 30 let's talk about that
that and it's also a personal journey
for you I know that you've said that
your first presidential vote went to
Norman Thomas socialists in 1948 and
then the other presidential vote that
you are that was easy for you to make
was that Clark in 1980 and yes the
libertarian candidate in an interesting
way I mean your journey as kind of
demarcated by those votes is a larger
American story of leaving behind a kind
of rule by elites or control by elites
where we'll take care of everything to
something much more individualistic and
you know kind of understanding that it's
a libertarian country not necessarily in
any specifics but that we need
decentralize power we need decentralize
decision-making what what destroyed
experimental economics destroyed
whatever was left in me in the notion
that that somehow you could do better
than to find institutions that organized
this decentralized information and
create you know that's that's the engine
of wealth creation in America I mean
since say 1952 to the current time
there's been a vast increase in the
appreciation of an understanding of
economics will we be better at kind of
not being stupid about how we're acting
even if we know more about economics and
the work that has to be done to keep us
from
getting off-track has to be expressed in
terms of of institutional constraints
when what we do has implications serious
implications for for innocent other
parties margin rules in the stock market
combine the damage to the people that
are doing it there's no external
blindsiding of all kinds of people that
are innocent you see I see it as a
property rights problem and you know we
got it right in most markets the vast
majority of markets work work fine and
and the reason why they work is that you
can't steal you have to trade what
essentially we're doing is asking
whether what was there a type of theft
going on that was not being controlled
you see by the right property right
regime federal spending currently is
twenty five percent of the economy a
figure that hasn't been seen since World
War two deficits looming large both in
absolute numbers as well as a percentage
of the economy is that a form of theft
as well as is that something that
concerns you and that needs to be reined
in
we're prompt I'm really gonna solve that
problem by inflating out of it mm-hmm I
think very matter I am very sorry to
hear that yeah and I'm sorry to say it
but I think that will be the way we
reduce the burden of the debt it won't
be intended Ben Bernanke talks about the
tools he has one of the tools he has is
to raise the interest rate he pays on
excess reserves in other words pay them
not to not expand loans rapidly if we
get into that but right now he's got the
other problem but is this also the
delusion of the economic planner that
once things start happening he's very
smart he's gonna be able we control this
and we've seen this before right where
inflation isn't a problem until it's
beyond control it's really interesting
to look at the Federal Open Market
Committee press releases in 2007 on
August 7th 2000
the press release said the housing
market is going through an adjustment
we're still concerned about inflation
three days later because of the collapse
when the credit default obligation
market that completely changed the
Federal Reserve Bernanke realized that
they had a financial crisis on their
hands that's how quickly it happened and
it was the signal came from a market it
did not come from the econometrics
models I think it's to Bernanke's credit
he changed he turned on a dime how many
times said he had said that was not the
business of the Federal Reserve to to
rescue investors from the consequences
of their own decisions that's exactly
what he ended up doing I don't believe
he wanted to do it I think he meant the
earlier statements but he had no choice
if we hadn't bailed out the banks if we
hadn't had tarp wheat the economy would
have ceased to exist
I think the more important thing was
what the Federal Reserve did not the
Treasury program you can always go back
and think and say well things should
have been done earlier to prevent that
from happening yes yes I agree but the
point is what are you doing that case
here it is and in spite of what every
mistakes what that had been made before
and you know Bernanke is testing the
Friedman Schwartz when I pollicis right
now that if the Fed had acted and and
flooded the system with liquidity in
early 30s that would have prevented the
Great Depression economists enjoy
possibly unprecedented kind of cultural
power I mean they can write best-selling
books they can run the world economy and
whatnot where does economics as and as a
serious discipline need to be moving
next to me the major problem in economic
theory is a preoccupation with modeling
for its own sake and and not asking the
fundamental question and these
fundamental question
I think have to do with dynamics they
have to do with property rights basic
questions like how can it be that
specialization exchange and property
rights could have come about you can't
have one without the other we think
today of property rights as something
that's determined by the state that
comes from the state that couldn't be
how they were they originated our small
group experiments you know our trust
games imagine that game in which I'm a
first mover and you're the second mover
I move first
I can choose ten dollars for each of us
or I can pass to you if I pass to you
the $20 becomes 40 you can give me 15
and keep 25 or you can give me nothing
right and get the whole 40 okay and game
theory says I should never pass to you
because if you're self interested you'll
take the 40 well what's remarkable is
half the people that we recruit into
undergraduate lab the half of the first
movers move of the second and two-thirds
to three-quarters of those reciprocate
with 1525 they don't take the total of
you can't understand that with game
theory you can understand it by reading
the Theory of Moral Sentiments it's not
a learned behavior or is that an innate
behavior is that dichotomy not raised
adam smith's he says imagine a human
being is brought up in complete
isolation from any member of the species
he says that person can't have an idea
as to what it means for his mind to be
deformed any more than he has an idea of
what it means for his face to be
deformed bring him into society and you
give him the mirror he needs if you read
the Theory of Moral Sentiments Adam
Smith is saying but never since is the
only thing that requires reward you
don't reward justice what you do is
punish injustice
justice is what's left over right you
see after you prevent injustice so the
property rights come out of human
sociality and then eventually get in the
civil government but they arise
originally in small groups we've been
talking with Vernon Smith of Chapman
University Nobel laureate in economics
thanks so much Vernon thank you for
recent TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you